first if the Americans have not
responded to the Iraqi invasion of
Kuwait that would have left a permanent
change I think for the worse in the
regional balances of power and the
method by which Iraq took over Kuwait
was keenly totally unacceptable i mean
the basic breach of international law
and it was always an American choice not
to and if Saudi Arabia hadn't wanted
them to it have been very hard for the
Americans to respond if the Emir of
Kuwait hadn't escaped it would have been
very hard for the Americans to respond
but they have that they have the choice
and they took it and I think you know at
the time I thought it was the right one
then and I think in retrospect I still
would would say that I think the
difficulty second time around is that
there was an untenable position in Iraq
I mean I don't find very hard to believe
you had a stable status quo that somehow
was only destabilized by American action
at some point something would have
happened in Iraq II the other than the
situation was durable but the way that
it happened and the timing was happened
and the reasons given meant that the
regime was overthrown on what seemed to
be at the time of contrived basis and
then most catastrophic Lee without any
real sense of what was going to happen
so it was order on the basis of the
worst-case analysis of what would happen
if you didn't overthrow Saddam Hussein
the term how they would build weapons of
mass destruction that they would go to
al-qaeda combined with the best case of
what would happen if you did go to war
cheering crowds cheerful liberation
beacon of the
bakra see help Israel whatever and which
is why it's all been a crushing
disappointment now in the end it may you
know may well be the case that Iraq will
be far better off in the future because
the battery team Saddam's regime has
gone but it certainly happened in the
most painful way possible both of the
Iraqi people I mean kind of the same
extensive davillon I think I think he
was content with containment he didn't
probably correctly see Iraq as a country
that was going to suddenly burst out of
it chains and suddenly caused major
problems again and if Saddam was still
there then that was a fault of his
predecessor rather than him I think also
for the first few years he was a very
interested in foreign policy took a
while before he did so I think the
problems i found and some was the
clinton regime quite hard to resume
printed administration it is legitimate
intend to use regime for illegitimate
government the clinton administration
was the hardest to judge because he
didn't have strong policies on any of
the issues he was always trying to make
the politics work to produce the outcome
that was most acceptable at home and
most acceptable in the region but was
never really prepared to take very bold
decision to do anything about it he had
an opportunity with Iran which may have
been even greater than the war with Iraq
I think it rock was a reasonably
intractable problem which you would let
rumble on until saddam saddam died or
there was a coup or something happened
there to give you an opportunity to move
in but with iran had a chain
of regime me neither President Khatami
came in who was clearly interested to
see whether something could be worked
out with the United States and it was
very tricky because I ron was is very
divided amongst its a lead some parts
were amenable to deal with the United
States and parts very hostile but again
he never quite changed the framework of
the debate on map that we started to do
so and then of course there was the
arab-israeli dispute well you know very
belatedly he had this big effort with
the Palestinians he'd already tried with
the Israelis and Syrians and you sort of
feel looking back that he never quite
imposed American views or his views on
what a proper outcome should be he was
always trying to work out how far could
you push the Israelis without it making
too difficult for the Israeli government
back home difficult for himself with
with Israel supporters in the United
States how he never really was saying
well this is what we think a good
settlement would look like what he was
saying is we think there should be a
settlement and what we want to help your
guy you guys as much as we can to reach
them but in the end it's your
responsibility and of course in the end
it has to be their responsibility but if
the Americans are involving themselves
that way with a clout and the prestige
in the influence the Americans have you
sort of sense that there was a clear of
view from him about what was desirable
might have gone helped helped a bit not
let somebody do send by the time his
presidency
it's hard to think the start I think
there was some history may take a
different view as things stand at the
moment there was some fundamental errors
I don't think those errors were in
chasing after al-qaeda in Afghanistan I
think any American president defective
done that and if I've been talking about
this in sort of late 2001 and a fool I'd
have said actually so far this has been
handled all panel pretty well the right
things have been said there's a lot of
America there's a lot of international
support for the American position you
now need more political period to build
on that support and start to create the
conditions in which groups like al-qaeda
can't flourish and two mistakes were
made at that point one was to exaggerate
the success in Afghanistan just because
the Taliban had fallen didn't mean to
say that you had a stable country in
which all elements of Islamist influence
were was suppressed you know Afghanistan
needed there a need still a lot of work
but the I was taken off that wall and
went to Iraq and there was no particular
need to go to Iraq at that point as i
said before at some point any American
president I'm sure would have found
themselves dealing with Iraq again but
the I think a lot of people went along
with the war because they thought this
really was an awful regime and we bet
the world would be better off without it
but it was the least propitious
conditions and to which to take it off
and then to be so ill-prepared for what
they then faced so in a flimsy case for
the war itself which i think you know
was believed in good faith i don't think
it was all made up but didn't last very
long and therefore
will drain some credibility from the
American effort but most of all when you
get to Iraq not to begin to understand
what it means to occupy a country of
this sword I think that whatever happens
to Iraq in the future you know tens of
thousands of lives have been lost years
have been lost Iraqi has the basis to be
a quite a strong prosperous even useful
country and at the moment is a drain on
themselves and everybody else the middle
class has fled it's someone going back
to tarian conflict has been aggravated
whole generation has lost their
education and health services are in
disarray they're dependent on
international aid and things haven't
really improved that much now i think
the policy now is more carefully tuned
and is surer than it was before but
that's an awful long way down the road
you can't rewind now you can't say well
we got it wrong that time let's try it
again the different way you can't you
use sir you're living with the
consequences of those decisions that
were taken in 2003